[Musique]
cette fin d'année se termine par la
signature d'une convention cadre entre
le département de la réunion le ccs et
la mairie de saint-denis dans la salle
de mariage cet accord officialise une
intelligence institutionnelles
importantes
c'est très concret parce que d'abord ça
a été voulue ça a été réfléchi on
s'était croisés nous avons regardé le
plan de relance du département et nous
avons regardé notre projet municipal
pour lequel nous avons été élus nous
nous sommes rencontré le président et
moi et nous avons regardé nos points
comme à un développement qui s'inscrit
dans le plan de relance initié dans
toutes les communes par le département
au répondre à cette urgence sociale et
ben la coordination que nous avons
constatée pour la période kobe des
services tcs communaux et du département
étaient évadés est essentiel pouvoir
répondre rapidement à la demande
donc c'est cette enseigne la crise qu
vide que nous essayons maintenant de
transformer et de et de capitaliser dans
le cas d'une convention de mutualisation
des services et des services publics
dans un salon de noël avec 35% de
chômage sur le chef lieu
cette grande ville n'échappe pourtant
pas une certaine précarité c'est le
travail du centre communal d'action
sociale qui agit dans toutes les crises
c'est pas mois de 800 mille euros donc
qui seront aussi à vis de l'action
sociale tant pour les sans abri que pour
le portage des repas et pour justement
amplifier cette aide qu'on a au plus
démunis au prêt à plaider plus les plus
démunis les plus éloignées en matière de
leurs difficultés sociales préserver la
biodiversité en améliorant le cadre de
vie
promouvoir l'aménagement du territoire
centrée sur le développement durable ou
encore accompagner les publics
vulnérables par effet de synergie de
compétences est aujourd'hui plus qu'hier
une nécessité
[Musique]